عن مضمون خطه السلام الصينيه لتسويه
سياسيه في اوكرانيا على ضوء الخطوط الحمر
التي وضعتها كياف بما في ذلك عدم تنازل عن
اراضي لروسيا التي تحتل مناطق في شرق
البلاد وفي جنوبها مرورا ايضا بموقف موسكو
الذي يميل الى التصعيد عسكريا وربما
باستخدام الاسلحه النوويه للاستمرار في
الحرب مع التاكيد على عدم التنازل عن
اراضي اعتبرها الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين انها
روسيه تاريخيا معي في الاستوديو الزميل
عبد الله العالي مساء الخير عبد الله بعد
زياره اعلى مستوى او مسؤول صيني عن سياسه
بلادها الخارجيه هل تعلن بيكن عن خطه
لانهاء الحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا
بالنسبه فعلا هذا الموضوع واكدته عده
مصادر صينيه واكدت ايضا الطابعه الوشيكه
للاعلان عن هذه الخطه الصينيه لايجاد
تسويه سلميه للحرب في اوكرانيا لكن هناك
بعض الغموض حول مضامين هذه الخطه وهناك
ايضا بعض الغموض عن ما اذا كانت قد تمت
بلورتها وصياغتها فعليا اما انها ما زالت
في طور التبلور لاننا اذا نظرنا الى ما
قاله وزير خارجيه اوكرانيا نجد انه قال
بان
الصينيين عرضوا عليه ولا سيما
الذي يعتبر على مسؤول عن السياسه الخارجيه
في الصين عرض عليه ما سماها الافكار
الرئيسيه في المبادره الصينيه على هامش
مؤتمر ميونخ للامن الدولي لكنه امتنع عن
ابداء راي فيها لانه قال بانه لم يتمكن
بعده من دراستها بشكل تفصيلي اما وزير
خارجيه روسيا فقال كما اشرت الى ذلك قبل
قليل كريمه بانه تباعث مع نظيره الصيني
بشان الافكار الصين حول الجذور العميقه
للازمه الاوكرانيه وعن مقاربات لتسويه
سلميه لهذه الازمه لكن بالنسبه للصينيين
لا خلاف ان هنالك خطه
تعلن قريبا وانها ستحمل عنوانا وثيقه
للبحث عن حل سياسي للازمه في اوكرانيا
وانها تامل ان تحظى بتعاطن ايجابي من قبل
الطرفين طيب هل هناك معلومات عبد الله عن
مضمون هذه الخطه الصينيه المسؤولون
الصينيون لم يقدموا حتى الان بشكل رسمي اي
مضمون من مضامين هذه الخطه لكن حينما ننظر
الى التصريحات الصادره عنهم وعن ايضا ما
ينشر في الصحافه الصينيه هذه الايام بشان
الازمه الاوكرانيه نجد ان هنالك بعض
تخزين القوى بين الصين نفسها وبين المعسكر
الغربي بقياده الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ومن الواضح كذلك ان الصين تضع محددا اخر
وهو ضروره احترامي حدود الدول وسيادتها
وهذا امر قد يؤول لصالح الاوكرانيين لكنها
من جهه اخرى الصين تقر مبدا اخر في
سياستها الدوليه وسياسه الدوليه التي تريد
لباقي الدول ان تكرسها وان تعمل بها وهو
مبدا الاخذ في الحسبان للهموم الامنيه
المشروعه للدول الاخرى وهذا امر قد يقود
الى ان تضع الصين مثلا في خطتها بندا او
بنودا تفضي الى ابعاد حدودي حلف الشمالي
الاطلسي عن روسيا الذي تعتبر الصين انه
كان اي محاوله الغرب لتمديد حدود حلف
الشمال الاطلسي ونطاقه
نحو الشرق لكي يقترب كثيرا من روسيا انه
كان احد الاسباب الرئيسيه لاندلاع الازمه
التي افضت في الاخير الى بدء الاجتياح
الروسي الاوكرانيا طيب عبد الله هل يمكن
النظر الى بيكين على انها طرف محايد في
النزاع بين روسيا واوكرانيا
اذا اردنا هل هي طرف محايد في النزاع
العسكري او في الحرب يمكن القول نعم لانه
لا يوجد دليل حتى الان على ان على ان
الصين قدمت دعما عسكريا قدمت اسلحه او
ذخيره
لروسيا وكل ما تم التاكد منه الان هو ان
الصين فعلا قدمت طائرات باعت طائرات
المسيره لروسيا ولكنها طائرات مسيره ذات
استخدام مدني وباعت نفس الطائرات ايضا
لاوكرانيا ثم ان هو ايضا لم يستطيع اي احد
ان يحصل على معلومه تفيد بنوع من الدعم
العسكري
باستثناء صور التقطتها اقمار صناعيه روسيه
ووجدت لدى مرتزقه فاجنر الذين يعملون على
الاراضي الاوكرانيه اذا باستثناء ذلك لا
يوجد حتى الان ما يمكن وصفه بالدعم
العسكري او التورط العسكري الصيني في
الحرب الدائره بين اوكرانيا وبين روسيا
لكن بالمقابل الصين تدعم دعما اقتصاديا
روسيا والدليل على ذلك ان المبادلات
التجاريه التجاريه بين البلدين ارتفعت
خلال عام واحد ب 30% وانها بلغت 190 مليار
دولار واغلب هذا المبلغ هو في الواقع
صادرات روسيه الى الصين ومن هذه الناحيه
فان الصين ساعدت روسيا في التغلب على
معاناتها الناتجه الاقتصاديا عن خساره
علاقات
اقتصاديه وتجاريه مهمه مع الدول الغربيه
وعلى راسها الاتحاد الاوروبي
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه الامر الثاني
ايضا ان الصين لا تخفي دعمها السياسيه
والدبلوماسيه لروسيا والدليل على ذلك هذه
الزياره التي قام بها قبل يومين فقط من
الذكرى الاولى لاندلاع الحرب في اوكرانيا
الذي يعتبر رئيس المكتبي مكتب العلاقات
الخارجيه في اللجنه المركزيه للحزب
الشيوعي الصيني الحاكم وهو اعلى مسؤول عن
السياسه الخارجيه الصينيه محرر شؤون
الدوليه عبد الله العالي شكرا جزيلا لك